robotic process automation
is in demand and is highly growing field
robotic process automation
is the use of software with artificial
intelligence and machine learning
capabilities
to handle high volume repeated tasks
that were previously required humans to
perform
python is an interpreted high level
general purpose
programming language rpa when interfaced
with
python helps users to transform tds task
and business process
into automated process hey everyone i
welcome you all to this session
in this session we will see how python
is
interfaced with rpa tools like uipath
and automation anywhere
let's look at today's agenda we shall
begin with ui path
and see the different python activity
packages that it offers
followed by which we will look at the
hands-on demo in the uipath studio
proceeding further we will jump into
automation anywhere and look at the
python script package
and look at the demo in automation
anywhere using python
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel
and clicked on the bell icon so you
never miss an update from simply learn
so without wasting any further time
let's get started with rpa
using python ui path using python
to invoke a python script in uipath we
must first create a new sequence
then we should drag and drop the
following activities from the python
activities pack
we need to drag and drop python activity
scope load python activity
invoke python activity and get python
object
then we will use a message box to
display the result variable
let's jump into the uipath studio and
explore
each of these activities in detail the
first thing we should do is go to the
manage packages
and install python activities pack
go to all packages and search the
keyword python
and here you will get
uipath.python.activities
so install this package click on install
and get it
installed so i have already installed it
so i'll close this
so let's create a new sequence we'll
name the sequence as
python demo let's create the new
sequence
now that we have installed the python
activities package
search for python keyword and you will
get the python activities package
so this pack allows you to call python
scripts
and methods straight from any workflow
you may also provide input parameters
and obtain the output data generated by
the activities to the invoked code
so the activities present in python
activities pack
are get python object invoke python
method
load python script python scope and run
python script so first we will drag and
drop
python scope so python scope is a
container
that sets up a python environment and
provides a scope
for python activities all python objects
loaded up to that point are erased when
the python scope activity finishes
so we need to provide the path where the
python is installed
so the prerequisite site is you need to
have python installed in your system
the latest version of python so search
for python
where it is installed in your system and
go to the file location
since this is a shortcut go to the file
location
and copy this file location and paste
the
location here in the path paste it in
the double quotes
okay so now we have pasted the location
in the path
and target change it to 64 if it is
64-bit
and version you can change it to any
version which you have installed
the python version or you can keep it in
the auto so that's not a problem
so after dragging and dropping a python
scope
drag and drop load python script get it
inside this do activity
so here you can write the code or if you
have an existing file you can copy the
file path here
so i'll write a simple code so
write it in the double quotes so i'll
define a function
say i'll name the function as name
and i'll pass an argument same message
and pass argument as message and
return the argument okay so i've written
a simple code
i have defined a function and returned
that argument
so we'll create a variable here right
click
create variable and name it as say
script
you can name it anything name it as
script
okay the variable is created so this
load python script is the command that
converts python code to a python object
variable the generated variable can be
used to invoke the methods in the
code next we need invoke python method
invoke python method allows you to run a
specified method
directly in a workflow from a python
script the method containing script must
be first loaded into the environment
using the load python script activity
so we have first loaded it with the load
python script activity
then only we can use invoke python
method
okay now we need to provide the input
parameters instance and name
instance is the variable which we
created previously in the
load python script we created a variable
named
script so select that variable and name
is the function name which we had called
we had called the function name
as name right in the previous load
script
activity so we'll name the function here
so we have name the function as name and
we'll pass the input parameters
so we'll pass the input parameters here
since we are passing a string use double
quotes and
i'll pass the parameter as thanks
for watching this video
so i have passed this input parameter
okay now
in the result we need to create an
another variable
so last time we had created the variable
called script
so we'll create this variable as script
one okay next we need
get python object so drag and drop get
python object activity
bring it inside so get python object
this method returns the dotnet type used
in the python script
so go to the input python object enter
the variable which
you had created in the invoke python
method we had created a variable
as script two right script one so
select that variable it is the type
argument
is of type string select the type string
since we are
passing a string and in the result
create an another variable right click
and create variable and will name the
variable as
script 2. okay now we need a message box
to display the result but before that we
have used
load python script and invoke python
method get python object and python
scope
we have used four of this activity and
the one activity left is
run python script so this command allows
you to run python
code you can either type the code
straight into the activity
or give it a file so we will not use run
python script in this
project so after this much is done we
will search for a message box
so drag and drop a message box inside
the python scope
so we'll enter the message here the
result variable which we had created
in the previous activity get python
object
is script two so to display the message
we'll enter that variable script
two so we need to convert it to string
so enter the function
dot to string we'll concatenate it
with the text say
subscribe to our youtube channel
so we have concatenated a message so we
are all done
so we'll save it and click on
run and here you go you can see the
message
thanks for watching this video and
subscribe to our youtube channel
automation anywhere is one of the
leading robotic process automation
platforms
automation anywhere is built on the
world's most commonly used
automation and artificial intelligence
platform
automation anywhere using python in this
we will write inline scripts using the
command python script
and its machine learning capabilities
within the automation anywhere
we'll first login to the control room
and create a new bot
then we will drag and drop the following
actions from the python script package
we will use python script open execute
function
and python script close then we will add
a message box to display the result
variable
let's jump into the automation anywhere
control room
and explore the python script package
and each of its actions
in detail log in to the control room
enter the username and password
click on login once you have logged in
the control room
go to the automation click on create
new bot enter the bot name as
bot enter the description which is
optional
and select the folder where you want to
store the bot
and next click on create and edit
so the bot is successfully created go to
the search actions
and search for python script package
so the python script package contains
actions that enable python script
functions in a task
on the device where you wish to run the
script the relevant version of python
should be
installed version 2.x and 3.x of python
are supported by automation anywhere
the path of the python folder is
modified in the path
environment variable enter the python on
the command prompt to see if python
environment variable is set correctly
the python environment is set up
appropriately if it returns the python
version that is installed
so these are the list of activities in
the python script package
close action closes the session and
specifies the name
execute function executes a function
within the python script
execute script executes a script within
the python script
and open action opens a python file
so let's use open file now
drag and drop the python script open so
enter the new python session
so enter the session name by default the
session name is default
so let's keep the session name as it is
and there are
two options one is to import the
existing file if you already have the
file on your device
you can import it from the control room
file or desktop file or variable
the other way is to manually enter the
code
so we'll enter a simple code we'll
define a function
let us name the function as name and
we'll pass an
argument as message will return the
argument
message don't forget to give colon in a
function
so we have entered the simple two line
code select the python runtime version
if you have python version 2 installed
then select 2
if you have python version 3 installed
in your device then select 3.
now next drag and drop execute function
in the python execute function action
enter the python session as it is
default
enter the name of the function to be
executed in the previous action
we have named the function as name so
enter the name
of the function and arguments to the
function
so select the argument to the function
so we'll create a new variable
we'll create the variable as python
variable and it is of the type
string so we'll select the type string
you can select whichever type you want
but for now since we are displaying a
message
which is of the type string so we'll
select the type string
and enter the value which you want to be
displayed
so i'll enter the value as thanks for
watching this video subscribe to our
youtube channel
so i have entered the default value a
message which is of the type string
if you want you can enter the
description which is optional and
click on create and select so we have
created a variable
this supports only zero or one argument
you can't pass more than one argument
and assign the output to variable
so which is optional but we'll select
the variable which we created now
python variable and next we need a
message box
to display the variable so search for a
message box
drag and drop a message box enter the
message box window title
when the message box is displayed it
contains a title
so what title you want the message box
to be shown
so enter the title here so i'll keep as
it is the default title
automation anywhere enterprise client
enter the message
so to enter the message select the
variable which we created
choose a variable python variable click
s insert scroll bar after lines
so after how much distance you want the
message to be displayed in the message
box
so select those many number of lines
next click on
close message box after check this box
and it's recommended to at least keep 9
or 10 seconds
by default it is showing 5 seconds we'll
change it to
10 seconds so the message
box is done now when we have opened the
python script
we also need to close the python script
we'll go to the list view
and go to the python script package
and select close action
and in the close action make sure that
the session name
is same the session name which you
provided in the python script
open action and the python name close
and the python script close action the
session name should be same
let's save python what is successfully
edited and saved
let's click on run
so here you can see the message thanks
for watching the video and subscribe to
our youtube channel
so this window will close within 10
seconds so we had provided a
10 seconds closing window so the window
was closed within
10 seconds after the message was shown
then the
still the bot was running why because
after the message box we have provided
the python script close action
that is why the bot was still running
and closing the script
so your bot has run successfully if you
have
any doubts any queries regarding the
projects
both in ui path or in automation
anywhere or regarding python
please comment in the comment section
and we'll try to answer all of your
possible questions
and do watch our previous tutorials on
uipath and automation anywhere for
better understanding
so with that we have reached the end of
this video like and share it if you
found it interesting
thank you for being here keep learning
and stay tuned to simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here